BAKED SUMMATION AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR IT.
BUCK SEXTON, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU CAN MUST BE FREE.
>> Tucker: EVEN MSNBC HAS TO
ADMIT THAT THE CARAVAN WAS ON
WITH WEEKS PORTRAYING ED AS.
WATCH THIS ADMISSION.
>> THE TRUTH IS, THE MAJORITY OF
THE PEOPLE ARE PART OF THIS
CARAVAN, ESPECIALLY AS I'D COME
IF WE CAN MAKE AWAY ALL THE WAY
OVER THERE, WE'LL SHOW YOU, THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE MEN.
FROM WHAT WE HAVE SEEN, THE
MAJORITY ARE ACTUALLY MEN.
SOME OF THESE MEN HAVE NOT
ARTICULATED THAT NEED FOR
ASYLUM, INSTEAD, THEY HAVE
TALKED ABOUT COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES FOR A BETTER LIFE
AND TO FIND WORK.
>> Tucker: AND RICKY ACEVEDO
AS AN ANCHOR AT UNIVISION
AND A FREQUENT UNWELCOME GUEST
ON THIS SHOW AND HE JOINS HER
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
SO NOW THAT IT'S HERE AND THE
FACTS ON THE GROUND ARE
UNDENIABLE, CAN WE STOP LYING
AND ADMIT WHAT IS OBVIOUSLY
TRUE?
THIS CARAVAN IS NOT PRIMARILY
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN, IT'S
PRIMARILY MEN?
>> I FIND IT INTERESTING,
TUCKER, YOU ARE CRITICIZING
JOURNALISTS FOR PRESENTING A
PARTIAL VIEW OF THE CARAVAN
WHILE YOU'RE DOING THE EXACT
SAME THING.
>> Tucker: NO, NO, NO.
I'M CRITICIZING THEM FOR LYING.
THEY ARE LYING TOGETHER AS A
GROUP, READING THE SAME TALKING
POINTS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE OFF A SCRIPT
IN ORDER TO INFLUENCE ELECTION,
WHICH IS WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO.
THAT IS WHAT I'M ACCUSING THEM
OF DOING.
>> THE CARAVAN IS NOT A
MONOLITHIC GROUP, TUCKER 8,000
DIFFERENT STORIES, A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT REALITIES.
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNMENTS
ONLY NUMBERS, 11, 12%, HAVE ANY
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A GROUP OF
600, AMONG MORE THAN 8,000
PEOPLE, SO 90% OF THEM, THE
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE A
LEGITIMATE CLAIM TO A SILENT
PRAYER THAT IS ACCORDING TO THE
HOMELAND SECRETARY OF THE
UNITED STATES, KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
>> Tucker: FOR ONE THING, I
WOULD SAY IF 600 OUT OF 8000 ARE
"KNOWN CRIMINALS," THAT IS A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE THAN A
CROSS-SECTION OF THE AMERICAN
POPULATION.
WE ARE GETTING WAY MORE
CRIMINALS PER CAPITA THAN WE
HAVE --
>> THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GET
IN -- THERE ASYLUM REQUEST WILL
BE DENIED.
>> Tucker: IS A FACTUAL
MATTER, THIS IS WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
JUST BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD DOES NOT MEAN
YOU ARE ELIGIBLE FOR ASYLUM.
SO PLEASE ADDRESS BUCK SEXTON'S,
I THOUGHT VERY INCISIVE POINT,
THAT IF YOU ARE SEEKING ASYLUM,
YOU ARE, BY DEFINITION, REQUIRED
TO ASK FOR IT IN THE FIRST SAFE
COUNTRY YOU REACH, WHERE YOU
DON'T FACE A MORTAL THREAT, AND
THAT WAS MEXICO.
>> KEYWORD BEING SAFE, NOT A
COUNTRY WHERE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ARE BEING KILLED EVERY
YEAR ACTUALLY.
MORE THAN 500,000 PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN KILLED IN MEXICO IN THE
LAST DECADE OR SO.
SO IT'S NOT A SAFE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: OH, SO THAT LEADS
TO MY SECOND QUESTION.
THAT I KNEW YOU WERE GOING TO
SAY THAT.
LET ME ASK YOU THE LOGICAL
FOLLOW-UP, WHICH IS, IF MEXICO
IS SO DANGEROUS, THAT YOU COULD
NOT TAKE ASYLUM THERE BECAUSE
YOU ARE IN PERIL JUST BY
BEING IN MEXICO, THEN WHY ISN'T
THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF MEXICO
ELIGIBLE FOR ASYLUM IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> THIS IS THE THINK I, TUCKER.
YOU SEE THE IMMIGRANTS COME OF
CENTRAL AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS
GOING ACROSS MEXICO, THEY ARE
VICTIMS OF EXTORTION, RAAPE,
VICTIMS OF MURDER, SOMETIMES
THEY ARE RECRUITED BY CRIMINAL
GANGS.
THAT IS WHY THEY'RE MOVING
ACROSS MEXICO AND A GROUP
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY HAVE
SECURITY --
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTAND, THEY
WANT TO COME HERE, WE ARE A
GREAT COUNTRY, I DON'T BLAME
THEM.
BUT I BLAME IS THE MEDIA, WHICH
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN A
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN N
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN E
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN F
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN R
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN T
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN O
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN C
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN N
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN I
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN C
HAS BEEN LYING RELENTLESSLY IN E
AMERICANS OF THINGS THAT AREN'T
TRUE.
SO LET ME ASK YOU -- LET ME PIN
YOU DOWN HERE.
YOU HAVE SAID --
>> THAT'S A FAIR CRITICISM.
>> Tucker: MEXICO SIDE, WE
WILL SHELTER YOU, --
>> WE INSIST PUTTING THE LABEL
ON THE CARAVAN AND AGAIN, JUST
FRAMING THIS IN ABSOLUTES --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
ADVISE THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
MEXICO, SINCE YOU SAID IT IS TOO
DANGEROUS TO LIVE IN, WHY
AREN'T THEY ALL ELIGIBLE FOR
ASYLUM IN UNITED STATES?
A SINCERE QUESTION.
>> IS IT OBLIGATED?
OF HAPPY TO --
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT
COMPLICATED.
>> THERE ARE MORE THAN
130 MILLION PEOPLE IN MEXICO.
FOCUSING MAINLY ON BORDERING
STATES WITH THE U.S., AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, SO NOT
130 MILLION ARE IN PERIL BUT IT
IS A DANGEROUS COUNTRY AND IT IS
A COUNTRY WHERE VIOLENCE --
>> Tucker: HOW MANY MEXICANS
WOULD YOU SAY -- IF IT IS SO
DANGEROUS, SPITBALL ED FORD, ARE
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWS,
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWST
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWSO
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWSC
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWSM
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWSE
ELIGIBLE, UNDER OUR ASYLUM LAWSH
UNITED STATES?
>> YOU SHOULD ASK THEM THE
IMMIGRATION JUDGE A QUESTION AND
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE
CHANCE --
>> Tucker: EVERYONE HAS A
RIGHT TO COME HERE?
>> THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO JUDGE THE MERITS OF AN
ASYLUM CLAIM.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU REFUSE
OVER GENEROSITY, WE BECOME LESS
GENEROUS.
>> TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
NUANCES IN HIS COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT JUST ONE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
YOU ARE THE ONE WHO TOLD ME IT
IS ALL WOMEN AND KIDS IN
STROLLERS.
YOU TOLD ME THAT.
>> AGAIN, LET'S GO BACK TO THE
NUMBERS.
THE OFFICIAL NUMBERS, ACCORDING
TO CDP, THEY ARE MAJORITY OF THE
REST OF THE BOARD ARE FAMILY
UNITS, WOMEN AND CHILDREN.